ce matin là j'avais laissé mon vélo au
garage il faisait froid il faisait nuit
nous étions en décembre ils étaient 5h15
du matin j'avais commandé un über le
chauffeur est arrivé j'ai embarqué il a
bifurqué sur la 39e rue puis sur
massachusetts avenue où nous avons passé
le watergate le washington monument et
quand j'ai dit au chauffeur que j'allais
voir le cercueil de georges bush ils
étaient étonnés étonné qu'un étranger se
lève si tôt pour aller voir la dépouille
de son président défunt il m'a parlé de
george bush d'autres présidents et nous
étions déjà arrivé au capitole la grande
place devant le capitole était vide
j'étais parti si tôt pour éviter les
queues et arriver à l'heure à ma séance
de 10h à la banque mondiale mais il n'y
avait pas que j'ai passé la sécurité
traverser les couloirs et je suis arrivé
dans la rotonde du capitole
face à moi le cercueil de georges bush
recouvert d'un drapeau américain et là
une lumière rouge sur une caméra est-ce
que j'étais live sur cnn
d'abord j'ai voulu me cachais j'étais
gêné et puis j'ai pensé que peut-être
son george bush je n'aurais pas pu faire
mes études en ex-allemagne de l'est un
joggeur est venu se mettre à côté de moi
je les regarde et il était en habit
jogging chaussures de course à pied et
je me suis dit on ne peut pas faire ça
et puis je me suis rappelé que je
n'étais pas en suisse
j'ai pris un bus pour le centre ville
j'étais le seul blanc dans ce bus qui
arrivait des quartiers pauvres de
washington je suis descendu non loin de
la maison blanche et j'ai marché un bloc
jusqu'à la banque mondiale je suis
arrivé bien à l'heure pour ma séance de
10 heures alors pourquoi je vous raconte
ça ce soir parce que ce moment n'a
marqué j'ai eu l'impression d'être le
témoin le témoin d'un moment d'histoire
des états unis le témoin d'un moment
intime vécu avec les américains et ce
genre de moment est emblématique de la
curiosité qui m'habite
le voyageur il est en mode découverte il
a six antennes ouverte il fait preuve de
curiosité
le voyageur il n'est pas chez lui il
essaye de comprendre ils essayent de
comprendre sans juger
il fait preuve d'empathie
quand j'avais 9 ans je voulais devenir
journaliste je pensais que c'était le
métier le plus à même de rassasier ma
curiosité et puis je me suis rendu
compte que les lieux étaient importants
pour moi quand j'allais à l'école de mon
village de belfaux à fribourg je passais
tous les matins devant la gare des bus
de fribourg et je voyais des bus avec
des destinations comme jaun bull
avenches schwartz et et plus d'une fois
j'ai rêvé prendre un de ces bus et
m'évader pour la journée
le 9 novembre 1989 le mur de berlin est
tombé j'avais 14 ans je regardais à la
télévision ces allemands de l'est qui
passait pour la première fois à berlin
ouest
je commençais à m'intéresser au monde et
à quelques centaines de kilomètres de
mon village des gens traverser un mur le
sourire aux lèvres
j'étais fasciné par cette allemagne qui
se réunifier et sans savoir je me
préparais au nomadisme
j'ai passé mon bac à fribourg et j'ai
dessiné
commencer des études en allemagne
j'avais le choix entre leipzig byron
minds hambourg et berlin
et lors d'un enterrement à montagny les
monts j'ai demandé à un berlinois quel
serait son choix et il m'a répondu du
tac au tac guénard lights et d'asie ce
diktat tel optimisme hausse
j'ai commencé des études de sciences
politiques et d'études africaines à
leipzig j'ai aussi très vite rejoint le
choeur de l'université de leipzig je
voulais chanter du bar dans la ville où
il a hérité kantor le choeur de
l'université de leipzig est vite devenu
ma stammtisch mme ashton tige au premier
sens du terme pour toutes les bières et
les discussions que nous avions après
les deux répétitions hebdomadaires dans
une clinique mais aussi ma stammtisch au
sens plus large du terme pour toutes les
rencontres toutes les amitiés que j'ai
pu nouer avec d'autres choristes dont
beaucoup venaient d'allemagne de l'est
c'était la première fois que je partais
vivre à l'étranger et j'ai dû apprendre
à avoir le mal du pays de m'ennuyer de
mes montagnes de ma famille de mes amis
le voyageur il a besoin de s'intégrer
de trouver ses compagnons de route c'est
bodies ils cherchent le contact
pour cela il a besoin du stammtisch
le voyageur il vient de quelque part il
ya bien un endroit où son voyage a
commencé il a des racines un terroir il
n'oublie pas d'où il vient il a toujours
un morceau de gruyère dans sa poche
j'ai continué mon voyage à dakar où j'ai
étudié une année puis à berlin où j'ai
travaillé pour la télévision française
et après huit ans passés en allemagne et
au sénégal je suis rentré en suisse
il y a cinq ans mon épouse mes deux
enfants et moi-même sommes partis à
washington j'avais décroché un contrat
de quatre ans à la banque mondiale un
job d que j'entende journée entendu
parler je me suis dit je le veux et j'ai
commencé à écrire ma lettre de
motivation dans ma tête j'ai eu de la
chance je les ai eues mais je me suis
vite rendu compte que partir seul à
leipzig avec deux valises c'est
différent que de partir avec sa famille
un container de 40 pieds et un chat
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
quand vous déménagez avec votre famille
c'est comme si vous déménagez une paix m
il faut que toute la petite entreprise y
trouve son compte il nous a tous fallu
plus ou moins de temps pour nous
acclimater à washington et moi
j'applique est la méthode cesc curiosité
empathie stammtisch et gruyère que je ne
connaissais pas encore à l'époque la
curiosité avec ce vélo j'ai parcouru des
centaines de miles more washington pour
voir j'ai vu les manifestations de
blacklight matters j'ai vu les gens qui
faisait la fête devant la maison blanche
le jour de l'annoncé de la victoire de
joe biden et j'ai vu les barrières
fleurir dans to machine tonnes suite à
l' attaque du capitole
pour l'empathie je suis arrivée à
washington avec des lunettes européenne
où je devrais dire peut-être même des
lunettes fribourgeoise et je me suis
rendu compte que mes lunettes étaient
très différentes des lunettes américaine
on a l'impression parce qu'on regarde
les mêmes séries télévisées les mêmes
films que l'on connaît les américains
mais on oublie souvent que cela fait
plus de trois cents ans que notre
histoire est différente
mme ashton tish je les trouvais à la
banque mondiale avec des collègues du
monde entier nous nous réunissions une
fois par semaine autour d'une grande
table ronde dans la cafétéria de la
banque mondiale pour discuter de projets
de dossiers et grâce à cet outil j'ai
trouvé mes bêtises j'ai trouvé les
collègues avec qui j'ai pu faire avancer
ses dossiers et ses projets et certains
de ses collègues sont aussi devenus
désuets
et le gruyère le gruyère
j'avais trouvé dans le washington post
par chance un supplément qui
paraissaient tous les mercredis le
supplément food et dans ce supplément il
avait un magasin de vins et de fromages
qui faisait de la publicité
et quand le gruyère de rue en suisse
gris renaudié remarqué juan était
annoncée à 11 $ la livre ja pourrait sur
connectique est venu pour faire le plein
de vitamines
voilà après quatre ans aux états unis
nous sommes maintenant de retour à
fribourg
4 mo curiosité empathie stammtisch et
gruyère la curiosité la curiosité c'est
se laisser aller dans le choix de ses
destinations c'est faire ce qu'il faut
pour que les choses surviennent la
curiosité c'est le road trip pas
l'heureux tuer pour vous préparer tout à
l'avant ce nom le 28 pour ne savait pas
le matin vous allez dormir le soir le
road trip où vous longez le mississippi
et que par hasard vous tombez sur le
village de popeye leurs hôtes 8 vous
vous êtes perdu au milieu du kentucky et
que vous voyez sur la carte juste de
l'autre côté du fleuve hoyau une
localité dénommée tel city pour willem
tel et que vous décidez de faire le
détour pour aller voir cette ancienne
colonie suisse
et parfois la vie s'apparente à un road
trip quant à berlinois me dit d'aller
étudier à leipzig et que sans trop
réfléchir j'en fais mon choix quand je
trouve une petite annonce à l'université
de leipzig pour une année des changes à
l'université de dakar et que j'en fais
mon projet ou bien quand j'entends qu'un
job se libère à la banque mondiale un
job très intéressant et que je commence
à écrire ma lettre de motivation dans ma
tête
et encore une chose quand je lis dans le
washington post que le cercueil de
georges bush sera exposée au capitole et
que je mets mon réveil pour le lendemain
matin à 5h
la curiosité ces maisons ten et si la
curiosité c'est mes antennes alors
l'empathie c'est me lunettes quand vous
arrivez dans un pays étranger
vous êtes nouveau les gens voient que
peut-être vous parler différemment que
votre apparence est différente mais
c'est un avantage cela vous permet de
poser toutes les questions d'essayer de
comprendre le contexte les gens mais il
ya un danger c'est celui de tout ramener
à l'endroit vous avez vos racines de
vous dire hein ça c'est moins bien que
chez moi ça c'est mieux que chez moi et
une fois j'ai posé une question naïve un
un ami est-allemand et c'est parfois en
posant les questions les plus naïves
qu'on a les meilleures réponses je lui
avais demandé est-ce que c'était mieux
avant ou après la chute du mur et micha
m'avait répondu laurent c'était pas
mieux avant ou après mais c'était
différent et quand vous vous dites que
les choses sont différentes alors tout
change
l'empathie vient directement il n'y a
plus besoin de juger et de se demander
si c'est mieux ici ou là bas
si la curiosité c'est mes antennes que
l'empathie c'est mes lunettes alors là
stammtisch c'est le lieu pour cultiver
cette curiosité et cette empathie
l'achetant tish c'est le lieu pour poser
des questions écouter comprendre vous
rappelez de lâcheté m'chich du bistrot
du village cette table souvent ronde à
l'entrée du bistrot ou des habitués
venait à certains moments de la journée
ou de la semaine il commandait une bière
posait des questions certains parlaient
d'autres parlent pas du tout et après
deux ou trois bières il repartait avec
les dernières nouvelles du village et
avec la satisfaction d'avoir passé un
bon moment
avec le temps je me suis rendu compte
que la stammtisch et 1 excellent moyen
de communiquer et d'échanger et rien de
mieux lors de changements que de pouvoir
participer à une stammtisch
le gruyère le gruyère c'est mon remède
au mal du pays c'est mon remède à la
nostalgie des préalpes de fribourg et de
tout ce que cette région représente pour
moi le gruyère c'est mes racines et
comme le gruyère je suis un produit du
terroir quand on voyage il est important
de savoir d'où on vient de connaître sa
culture de connaître ses racines et pour
le fribourgeois
voyageurs le gruyère c'est aussi une
excellente assurance
une assurance contre le coup de blues et
le mal du pays
vous en connaissez d'autres des produits
fabriqués dans les villages de notre
région que l'on retrouve sans trop de
problèmes à leipzig à washington et
peut-être même à dakar un morceau de
gruyère un coup de rouge et ça repart
voilà mes quatre manque curiosité
empathie stammtisch et gruyère la vie
est un long road trip et que de mieux
que d'être en mouvement en voyage pour
faire avancer sa vie pour trouver les
prochaines étapes et prendre des
décisions
quand j'avais 20 ans j'ai lu un livre
qui m'a marqué un livre de nicolas
bouvier lusage du monde
est dans ce livre il ya une phrase qui
est resté dans un coin de ma tête depuis
la première fois je les lui je vous dis
ce soir la vie est un long vos tweets et
nicolas bouvier le dit beaucoup mieux on
voyage pour que les choses surviennent
échanges sans quoi on resterait chez soi
[Applaudissements]